you know as somebody who was
it's like i can't win like whether i'm
fat
you [ __ ] hate me if i'm losing weight
and i'm doing things for myself
you [ __ ] hate me so why the [ __ ]
should i care at this point so i feel
terrible for her it's like she can't
just live
you have to now like shut off your fans
who are against you for
being healthy like um i
okay it's weird i relate i never would
say
i relate to this five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have
ed park back here again for another
episode
appreciate appreciate everything that
you guys have
said and like i guess that's what we
want to get into it's just uh
i got so many responses for those last
couple
podcasts man yeah really great positive
messages
dude yeah there's that one she also
messaged me too about her relationship
her strained relationship with her
father yeah you know
i think like um i think that happens to
a lot of like asian american kids
right um specifically when it comes to
their relationship with their parents
the the perspective and the idea of like
uh having empathy towards them instead
of always asking them to empathize with
us
it's not something that a lot of these
asian kids are thinking about at a young
age anyways right that usually happens
when actually not even when you're older
some of my older friends did a bunch of
[ __ ]
yeah they still hate their parents they
still hate their [ __ ] parents you
know i actually saw something today
that i just 100 didn't agree with it was
this video of this [ __ ] one
some korean [ __ ] i think he's a com like
a comedian or something like that
let's use that word loosely yeah but but
you know this is going on this tirade
about like why
asian people don't support each other
and like
it stems from like our asian parents
telling us that we're not [ __ ] so we
believe it it's like
bro your parents bro that's your parents
my dad has never said i wasn't a i
wasn't [ __ ]
you know he wanted me to be successful
in the way that he saw
fit it was always to build me up it just
wasn't in the vision that i
thought i had so i don't know where
you're getting this idea that all asian
parents walked up and told them that
you're
that i'm sorry that your parents called
you a piece of [ __ ] probably because you
are
you know you [ __ ] trash bag that you
would go out on a public platform and
say that your parents would say that
about you i don't know your parents
yeah but to say that that's like the
generic asian-american experience
is false no i no [ __ ] disagree with
that right i mean our parents can be
rough
sure but like um i know my dad's
intention behind calling me dumb was
because he knows i'm smarter
he makes more out of you yeah at the
least i can get past that [ __ ] bro
yeah you know because i know i'm
supposed to be smarter than that
yeah you know but if you were feeding it
and you're having an existential crisis
because
wait a second i'm not worthless and now
you're mad at your parents
yeah [ __ ] you dude yeah get the [ __ ] out
of here man
you've got time for that [ __ ] yeah go
have your own extension somewhere else
go hide in the corner and do this
watching this thing right and then i
think he's like a tick-tock or something
like that you know he's very ha you know
he's super happy about his tic toc
success as a comedian amazing
but um yeah but you know supposed to be
funny
but the whole spiel and the reason why i
didn't like this right and so a lot of
people were agreeing with what he was
saying from a lot of these asian kids
and you're gonna grow up and you're
gonna find out how [ __ ] wrong you are
this is not an opinion to me to me this
is a fact anyways and
it's the point of saying um uh asian
people
um are considered like submissive or
weak because
we just take [ __ ] all the time and we
don't stand up for each other right
and the reason why i don't like that
statement is because when you say a
blanket statement like that
you're oversimplifying something that's
something that's a lot more complicated
yeah right
and so the point that he was trying to
make too he goes other we rather stand
up for other people's cultures than our
stuff
and i know what you're alluding to you
little [ __ ] you're alluding to the blm
thing
right you're not outright saying it
because you're a [ __ ] um but
you're saying and let me tell you why
that
doesn't make sense right and while
you're oversimplifying the situation
when you say asian american what do you
mean by that right when you say other
asians won't stick up for their their
brothers and sisters
who what do you mean by brothers and
sisters for example and the reason why
i'm saying you're oversimplifying the
situation is because you're comparing
apples and oranges to
black american culture and asian
american culture number one i'm not
saying both of us
aren't a monolithic culture we're not a
singular thing
but more so for asian people right
because of how we came to this country
yeah when i ask an asian person who they
are right i'm like hey what's your
ethnic background
do they ever say asian-american what do
they say korean-american
chinese-american japanese-american
japanese vietnamese
right this is how just
beautiful and eccentric our culture is
and our cultures even though we're all
from
asia there's it's so [ __ ] different
yeah
you know what i mean it's it's it's as
different as
america to asia as like vietnamese is to
korean yeah that's how different it is
that's why when you oversimplify stuff
and saying asian people don't support
asian people what do you mean by that
right it depends on what this person
identifies with and when you compare
that
to like black culture right you're
talking about a culture that was brought
to this country
as property and chattel yeah their
culture was stripped from them
purposefully through religious for for
religious purposes
their gods were fake they would beat
them they would enslave them they told
them like this is the truth
this is the way you do what we tell you
to do their culture was stripped from
them
our culture wasn't when we came to this
country we brought our stuff
here yeah we came here for opportunity
by
choice like we know we're korean for us
when we came here we actually have
this asian identity specific to where
we're from
that we come from right so when like i
say and the reason why i bring that up
when you say something as stupid as
as as [ __ ] dense and blunt as
we're all asian american i don't like
that
because it's not true we are asian
american 100 percent that's how the rest
of the world sees us but
when you ask an individual it's a little
more complicated we all think so
differently
we came fresh off of different wars yeah
we all came fresh off of different
conflicts different governments
different leadership
hey man like for some reason you
instilled in us not to
[ __ ] get france and germany mixed up
there's you know we're not
here being like the same [ __ ] white
people we're not [ __ ] doing that [ __ ]
yeah it's just like hey give us a
[ __ ] break stop calling us all the
same it's actually lightweight racist
yeah real it really is and so
when when you kind of dumb down a
situation like that and you say
and you start to say well asian american
people don't support other asian
americans
because they don't know that we're all
one it's because you're not
you're not out there that's probably why
you don't know what collaboration is or
that [ __ ] that we got
all the other asian american [ __ ]
organizations that down to help each
other out
you don't know [ __ ] about that if you
did you wouldn't have said that in the
first place yeah
not only that do you know that there's
museums and art shows in k-town that are
going on you want to experience they are
you want to experience the culture
it's there no it's [ __ ] there or
create it
you know you're sitting there being a
[ __ ]
resentful cynical [ __ ] [ __ ] jerking
off to your own resentment yeah and like
like in mouth and i think like when i
when i saw that video and i saw people's
responses
right and typically what i was reading
on those responses was like
and there's a lot of people who actually
agree with us too right and there's like
half and half and the the other half was
saying like
yeah whenever i try to stand up for i
feel like i have to stand up for uh
asian people more than my actual asian
friends will stand up for themselves
and they start making this stupid
comparison right to their parents and
this is where the disrespect comes where
i don't agree with this [ __ ] video at
all and i kind of want to slap this dude
but they're they're making a comparison
about our parents
our parents generation right they go
well you know
they don't want to say anything because
they're scared and this is why they
think that we're pushovers right
and i wholeheartedly disagree with that
number one
you talk big talk right now because you
were born in this country
and you speak the language and you are
thriving off the cultural milieu that
your parents
built for you to live in yeah that's why
it's easy for you to say that
so for you to go and judge your parents
who came to this country
with absolutely nothing not knowing the
[ __ ] language
and you're telling them to protest
during in the 60s
in the 50s when back then it was
dangerous for them to do so
it's not dangerous for you to speak up
for your rights right now
as an asian american like it was for
them back in the day so for you to sit
there in your privilege and judge your
asian american parents or asian parents
like they were pieces of [ __ ]
for not doing what you're doing when
they set the foundation for you shows
that you're [ __ ] trash
like i hate that you don't you don't get
to say that to your parents
i mean if your parents are trash bags
you know if they're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] or whatever right but i'm
talking about these hard-working
immigrant parents
and then not only did you expect them to
learn the language to
to to run a business or do whatever odd
jobs that they had to provide for you
your brother your sisters or whatever
and then their family members and send
it back over to vietnam
you know cambodia korea whatever that it
is right and then on top of that they're
like
why didn't you work for social justice
do you know what the okay that's another
part of it it's like
well do you know what your parents were
going through do you know the history of
korea
yeah and ask them that you know what the
[ __ ] the stone age is in the 1950s after
the korean war
yeah her parents grew up in the [ __ ]
stone age of korea they didn't have [ __ ]
they [ __ ] in the [ __ ] ground they dug
holes and [ __ ]
around okay and then you're like why
don't you stand up for free
right my mom watches
chingu like that movie we were talking
about before it's like literally she
tells me about like [ __ ] a hole in
the ground and like
my how many taking a live chicken and
throwing it in a pot alive
and boiling and boiling it and then the
fairy tale
feathers later you know like you like
that the hierarchy of
important things in your life it depends
on the situation that you're in
yeah so it's weird when i hear young
asian americans
go back and criticize their parents for
not being social justice warriors
when they had bigger things to deal with
at the time yeah okay so like
politically two in the 70s in korea
dictatorship yeah thousands of people
students especially young people
murdered getting murdered
so you know what our parents did they
[ __ ]
all bounced give them give them a
[ __ ] break yeah
all right when they were your age they
were [ __ ] getting threatened to get
killed by the government and then right
then you do this [ __ ] tick tock video
talking about
asian americans don't support each other
we're all brothers and sisters and we we
rather sit around and support another
movement instead of backing
ourselves up bro it's like fantasy you
choose to see the negative things
right you don't see all the positive
movement that's happening you rather sit
there and [ __ ] on your own culture and
call us weak
you think that our parents were
complacent they didn't know what was
going on when they came here
right they had to sit back and observe
and they were trying to survive
at the time and now you get to speak the
way that you [ __ ] do because the
foundation that was laid
by the generation before you so shut the
[ __ ] up like
hey instead of asking your parents that
who had what they had and how to deal
with what they did right
what about coca-cola right they were
around 1960s they didn't stand up for
the [ __ ] civil rights movement
they do now yeah you know why it's
called [ __ ] neoliberal
liberal capitalism just yeah [ __ ]
it's just our culture it's [ __ ]
happening now welcome to 2020.
can just understand we're in the [ __ ]
future right now you know
and it's not resenting the past you
think you can jump in a time machine and
get
start talking to your parents and make
it right for you now yeah this is what
it is now this is the cards we're dealt
with
mm-hmm it's like just streaming
minecarts suck
like there's a reason why you get to say
this [ __ ] bro there's a reason why
people
share that [ __ ] on tick tock it's
because your audience is the audience of
[ __ ] six-year-olds dude
so shut the [ __ ] up and you as an adult
now they're gonna believe you
and think that [ __ ] asian parents
suck yeah and that we're weak and we
don't speak up or something like that
for all the stories i've told about my
parents i'm
telling you that i love them man like
give me a [ __ ] break
you hate your parents not us exactly and
to say that blanket statement as if it's
a general truth for asian people saying
that
uh asi that we asian parents teach their
kids that they're not [ __ ]
i'm like dude your parents suck bro my
dad has never said that to me
yeah it's like that's the problem well
this is the problem with a lot of these
like influencers these
influencers speak on behalf of asian
americans
yeah i i dislike it so
much because all of us right because
what they're thinking that they're doing
is that they're thinking that they're
saying something very
poignant and they're uplifting our
culture you're actually not
you're saying false things you're
generalizing us yeah
we are not a monolithic culture there
are so many there's
it's so nuanced yeah and for for you to
give a
blanket dumb just general solution
we all got to band together and support
asian american things
it's not that simple because if you
identify yourself as an asian american
you're not speaking for the person that
identifies themselves first as a
vietnamese-american korean-american
first
and then asian american next so it's not
going to connect that easy
it's it's very passionate
like motivation to start some kind of
movement and that's what i'm saying like
bro if you just googled some [ __ ]
there's probably organizations around
you that yeah
doing exactly what you want to do just
join them just stop being angry man yeah
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] up man it's
[ __ ] happening man we're we're out
there we're trying our best
like what are you good now you're the
leader because you bitched about it yeah
that's what i'm saying man
that's why man that's why i'm saying i'm
a bit the biggest fan of the fang bros
man
[Laughter]
10 things that asian guys like
oh big fat okay okay so like uh we got
quote unquote uh i'm not it's not fan
mail but uh yeah
we had you and your fans and have been
teaming me
up and giving me so many crazy messages
positive messages for the last couple
podcasts and um saying thank you to you
so much for like uh you know just having
this
[ __ ] on pretty much and um
one girl was talking about how her dad
was also a gangster
yeah her dad you know did some you know
you know shady [ __ ] or whatever and she
had a lot of resentment
and then like she wrote that she was
listening to podcasts just bawling her
eyes out
and she just went straight to her dad's
workplace and just wanted to see her dad
and just
told him that she loved him you know and
i was just [ __ ] blown away by some of
these messages
and so i just want to take the time to
say thank you after all the [ __ ] talking
yeah i mean the important part of that
i'm glad that young lady got to take
away something from this because it's
important for people to understand like
i said empathy is key
not like i say forgiveness is not for
the other person it's for you
right because when you look at somebody
and you see that especially for our
parents and their circumstance that
they were just trying to do their best
you want somebody to give that same
type of grace to you too and i think
that's the part that uh
probably resonates with a lot of people
it's like damn i would like for somebody
to give that type of grace and
forgiveness to me one day
yeah and if you're not going to be out
there giving it to other people
then who to say that you deserve that
too
it's so tough to like not bring the
[ __ ] church [ __ ] into this yeah
but yeah it taught me how to forgive
yeah that's for sure
that forgiveness is the
one of the core principles of the gospel
and just humanity is that we have to
forgive
or else you will not live you will hate
and like i see the biblical wording of
it if you hate your brother
then you are liar you don't actually
love god yeah but it's the
truth is saying like if you hate your
brother you actually do hate yourself
you hate your parents you hate yourself
you know a lot of the stuff too
you know my cousin uh he's a pastor now
he he said something to me
years ago that i still use till this day
he said that sticks with me so hard
and there's something very small but he
said um the qualities that you hate in
somebody else is
the qualities that you hate in yourself
right it's like oh
[ __ ] it's facts it's big facts the
qualities that you hate
if somebody else is always the qualities
that you hate yourself because you see
yourself in them
that's why when you have friends who are
[ __ ] up yeah
you you're you're not you don't hate
them you're trying to do it out of love
because you could see yourself doing the
same thing you see potential in somebody
else
so a lot of the times when we point
these fingers it's like
oh hold on am i am i upset because this
person's a [ __ ] bag or it's because
you hate yourself because you do the
same things it's like [ __ ] oh
yes that's what it is because i see
myself in some [ __ ] head
and i'm like oh it makes me cringe i'm
like oh wait i did that
yeah that couple years ago it helps a
lot
i mean it's it's a sign of maturity if
you've ever cringed at yourself when
you're by yourself on the road or
you're taking a shower oh i do that any
time i see my old youtube videos
bro it's just a sign of maturity it just
means that you're growing and you don't
like that and you wouldn't do that
anymore dude when i look back at some of
my old youtube videos when i do these
rants
and you know people still watch it till
this day and then they and they love
them right
but when i watch it i want to [ __ ]
gouge my eyes
but that money kind of does count the
viewership is going upstairs
yeah and so when i when i see these
videos
i'm like i understand what i was trying
to say
and i don't understand what i was doing
but you said it very angry i said it
very angry and sometimes i did these
videos
uh and i said these things in you know
hyperbolic fashion
yeah because it would inside a reaction
from people right and i
these words that i said i believed in
100 yeah but then i would be very extra
and over the top with it in order for me
to get attention
you know which is why i went back to my
old yelp account and deleted my reviews
yo check that out so i actually deleted
all my uh
one star reviews okay yeah same i did
all my ones i deleted every single one i
did this
five stars i did this like maybe like
seven years ago so i
uh this is before i had restaurants and
everything else um except for a couple
of them because they were [ __ ]
terrible
like they damn near poison me and they
told me to [ __ ] off you know those
people i
i want them to never live you know but
those businesses eventually closed down
but there was this idea of me
i hated reading the stuff that i wrote
because it was so pretentious
it was so [ __ ] uh i was just i had my
nose up as if i am this
th who the [ __ ] am i to go ahead and
judge
exactly right so it was just it was i
was so pretentious about it but that's
the
that's the power of yelp because you say
that you're david so and you actually
have some [ __ ] background and food
yeah i have a
[ __ ] tongue of a horse that's a
smoker for half of my life and i thought
i was the [ __ ] about k-town
you know what i'm saying that's what
yelp does to you though you say that too
but look at me
i started putting one like one star
reviews on some [ __ ] like
like a few years later i'd be like who
the [ __ ] am i
like even like i don't even know how to
cook yeah so what am i even saying
that was my biggest thing about some of
these yelpers right like i look at them
i'm like i guarantee you
you've never picked up a pen in your
life so how dare you talk about cooking
technique
to this person who owns this restaurant
right now mind you you could feel like
the food is not great
and the thing about restaurants too by
the way guys when the food isn't great
they'll eventually close down
they don't need your help they don't
need your help to ruin their livelihood
see that's that's the thing like seven
years ago i went back and i looked at
this restaurant
and uh it was for this the place is
still popping by the way
it's popping so i didn't do [ __ ] to it
okay but it was this restaurant that had
this idea of putting
um sourdough bread and putting pasta in
it
carbs on carbs it's like yakisoba bread
right and i hated it
i thought it was terrible the pasta was
overcooked it tasted like
you know [ __ ] ravioli which is fine
because i actually like the camera if
you like it
you know yo chef boyardee hey get it
right every time
i know but you know i ate it and i wrote
this scathing review and i'm like this
is a gimmicky place
it was a restaurant in san diego i was
like this is gimmicky it's terrible or
whatever what not right
and i went back and i saw that review
and i didn't look at my messages
and the business owner messaged me and
they wrote hey i'm sorry you had such a
terrible experience
um we're trying to get better we're a
new restaurant if you can give us a
second chance please come in and i
didn't read this
all right and i'm like david so who the
[ __ ] do you think you are dude yeah like
you wrote this
scathing review trying to tarnish this
person's
uh image yeah and their passion and
their love when they're just trying
and you thought that it would you're
doing somebody a favor
and it's in the guise of me doing the
public a favor of making sure that
people don't have such a bad experience
like i did but it's really not what it
is
the reason why we do that is because
yelp rewards this snobbery
you become a yelp elite
you know your opinion matters because
you go out to eat more that means you
know
food please
please you know and they walk around
with the snobbery and i saw that and i
made sure
from when i went back and i saw that
this was seven years ago and i
think i wrote that prior to that two
years before that i deleted all my one
stars yeah
and i deleted my three stars the only
ones i kept four stars and five stars
yeah
and i was like i don't need to go out of
my way
to destroy somebody's livelihood and
number two
who the [ __ ] do you think you are you
know what's hilarious about yelp is when
you want to delete your one star reviews
they ask you why
and i had to write to them i'm matured
and i'm an [ __ ]
i literally wrote that and then they and
then it's gone you know yeah i didn't
have to or whatever but
the way that they set that up for you
like makes you grow up
which is hilarious even though they
facilitate that kind of behavior
like um like my
dog i have yelp reviews from my store
we have a one-star straight up all
across the board and this
and the reviews are true they're all
true
they're like yeah the lady there's night
but this the
her son that works there is an [ __ ]
and i'm like yeah and they'll say like
the [ __ ] that i said then i'm like yeah
i said that
i did say that too because you know [ __ ]
you yeah but the thing
like is i mean the hilarious part of
that is that nobody gives a [ __ ] about
uh yelp reviews about gas stations
that's what people review subway yeah
you are a piece of [ __ ] dude how dare
you review a subway
but going back to it too i found that
the the
the person who wrote one of these
reviews and was just straight up lying
about my store uh was saying my mom was
saying me no english meme no english
my mom never [ __ ] said that in her
goddamn life yeah
she can't speak english but she will
anyway okay
it's like that you know she's too proud
for that [ __ ]
yeah and like it's like this guy's
[ __ ] lying and i found out he's just
this
guy who works at an oil change shop and
has nothing better to do and he didn't
like the way our
cigarettes were priced and so he wrote a
shitty [ __ ] review yeah but
you know this small amount of power goes
to a lot of people's heads
and they love it they feed off it they
have nothing else in their life what
they like is the fact that they get this
yelp elite badge and it makes them feel
special
yelp has done a good job of capitalizing
on people's worth
yeah and so it gives them value
sacrificing the actual
businesses that you know make our
country run
at least you know i had to do that all
the time with the soft-serve place too
like if somebody writes a review and
they go
i did not like the way this tastes i'm
like hey cool that's fine that one
starts with dessert because they didn't
like it
here's what it is you know but when
somebody writes a review like i remember
i had to like petition some
like one star reviews they go this place
doesn't have any parking one star
i can't control that welcome to
koreatown [ __ ]
i know there's no parking anywhere
welcome no no but just welcome to l.a
who the [ __ ] do you think you're gonna
go
yeah so i'm like can i contest this like
because i think like one of the things
that uh yup does that i just don't stand
exactly there's no seats anyways and so
like one of the things that uh
i think yelp did a good job and they
allowed me to contest you actually have
to go into the store and try the product
okay and so in the written review they
didn't go to the store
and they wrote a review that like they
took the one those one stars down
good god you know which is like why did
you go out of the way to try to ruin my
business
just because you couldn't find parking
bro they're just driving down the street
look at that place it doesn't even have
parking yeah i'll do my favorite yelp
reviews is the ones where they think
it's a
it's their personal diary they go today
i woke up me and jimmy were supposed to
have a shower together but he didn't
feel like he was in the mood
so my day didn't start that well my mom
is an [ __ ] i'm going through therapy
right now and then they go
then they go let's get into the food
guys it's just [ __ ] your
entitlement people's blog that's what
yelp is yeah and then like
well let's talk about the ice cream i
had i'm like that's where you should
have started
i just hope if you guys have a yelp just
delete it
yeah just delete it it doesn't help
anybody you know write reviews but be
positive about it or if you don't like
it
like it's it clearly shows the cynics
and depressed people of the world
yeah yeah that was one of them i really
was
so so was i but look that's why we're
talking about it out loud about the show
yeah we
wrote the [ __ ] we wrote yeah they made
me feel really bad
you know speaking of that though we're
all going to talk about is actually
recently
you know we i i we did a video about
um adele so adele lost a lot of weight
right which is very interesting
and how that reaction was well there was
also another big star
uh that lost weight which is lizzo yeah
if you all know who lizzo is you must be
living under a [ __ ] rock her music
is [ __ ] popping personality is dope i
love everything about her oh yeah
you know uh she's definitely been the
the mascot
or the repre the representation for big
girls out there right right
in the face thinking the ways right and
she's really big now i'm not going to go
ahead and get into a whole diatribe
about health well maybe we'll bring that
up later in the podcast
but when she i guess she went on a
smoothie diet recently
and then i think she's vegan now okay um
she
was drinking a lot she wrote that she
was drinking a lot she was eating a lot
of spicy food so it kind of [ __ ] up
her gi tract
she wasn't sleeping well her skin was
terrible so she just decided to do
this raw diet smoothie cleanse to kind
of reset um
her stomach you know her butt her gut
her butt kyle
oh
so that's what she was uh doing this for
and she got a lot of great results she
goes
you know i love myself big or whatever
and whatnot i just did this for myself
and it feels good it feels fine
so there was a lot of backlash on
twitter saying like yo we thought you
were better than that
you were our big girl representation
you're not supposed to diet
yeah you're not supposed to die you know
these smoothie diets are dangerous and
the fact that you're promoting it
it's like yo this is let me tell you
what i really dislike about this right
well so before we get there uh before we
start talking [ __ ]
let's talk about our former fat boy you
know issues you were
how much have you almost 280 and you are
i'm 2 11 right now nice so i lost like
what 79 pounds or something
69 pounds something like that yeah
uh i was 240 250
i am 145. yeah so yeah 100 pounds
so we did our [ __ ] all right yeah we did
our [ __ ] so
uh we're going to start talking about
fat people and we're just going to talk
it openly about
fat people it's about obesity and fat
people fat fat fat
fat trigger warning fat yeah let's talk
about fat people okay it's
that that word fat and you guys have to
understand too
um i've been i was big my whole life and
i'm still on
i'm still like probably like 30 pounds
overweight and if i want to lose that
weight i'll kick it into gear
i'm not really uh interested right now
because quarantine yeah i will we'll
give you
right right yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna fix
that later on but as of right now i'm
perfectly fine but um you know when we
talk about lizzo
right uh the the issue that i have with
this is that we're talking about
something called body positivity
yeah i didn't realize that body
positivity was only pertaining to fat
people
that guy
just a guy who has like [ __ ] one arm
is like you know i suck the way this is
they're like [ __ ] you i'm [ __ ]
like fat that fat this is real
positivity
you know as a person who's still chubby
now and was it was
more on the more morbidly obese scale i
find that highly offensive yeah
you know and so when i was a highly
offensive but it's
more annoying as [ __ ] so so you only
supported lizzo because
what you're saying is that you only
supported lizzo because it supported
your personal agenda
and your personal emotions of not loving
yourself first of all
[ __ ] that's not her responsibility
that's on you
she never came out or maybe i could be
wrong but i don't think she came out
saying like
i want to be in the forefront of body
positivity for fat girls
i think lizzo was saying get the [ __ ]
off my back
i'm a fat girl i'm doing my thing stop
talking about my [ __ ] weight
talk about my talent talk about my music
i exercise i eat what the [ __ ] i want
i'm happy if i'm fat i'm [ __ ] fat
let's move on from this
so that's your agenda the the problem
with those people is that they
identify lizzo as the fat girl not the
talented girl not the singing girl not
the beautiful girl not that all this
and the fat girl with talent not the
talented girl who is that
and the funny thing is it's coming from
the people who are using her
as their martyr right they're using her
as
as their as their fat jesus to be like
it's okay to be this way yeah yeah and
then now that they they don't she
doesn't fit into their specific agenda
now they're giving her backlash and [ __ ]
for living her life so what do you mean
by body positivity
what you mean you don't mean body
positivity at all it's not
be happy with the way that you look you
can be skinny fat or whatever
it's you make me feel good about myself
because i feel terrible yeah that's what
you're saying and that's why i have a
problem
with these people who are cheering her
on saying like you
you you make it okay for me to love
myself for who i am right
but you still haven't fixed the issue
that you have with yourself because when
your knight in shining armor decided
that they weren't feeling healthy and
they did something for themselves
that didn't fit your agenda you wanted
to crucify her and i hate that
as it goes back to saying you didn't you
weren't thinking of her as the talented
musician you
know she was the fat girl that had
talent yes i hate that it was
just like i'm okay the way i
am and without realizing that maybe the
the the
habits that you're perpetuating to talk
about your condition yes i said
condition
because i was once fat i was once
morbidly obese
you and i yeah you know to attest to it
look i was in denial like i talked about
the
confidence i had that i i had as a fat
guy
when i looked in the mirror um i was
okay with myself to be honest
yeah to be honest i was okay like
because i accepted myself that is
healthy
that is positively healthy but when the
[ __ ] science and the doctors
and everyone tells you yo you're obese
like watch it
you know so even something crazier than
that this podcast is brought to you by
green chef if y'all are trying to chef
it up at home with
easy to follow instruction meals that'll
make you look and feel like gordon
ramsay
you better not sleep on green chef baby
i love my green chef meals it comes with
super easy follow instructions that
always ends up with a
delicious result i'm talking about hands
on experience
i made this shrimp and cabbage deal with
this bomb ass spicy sauce
i just told people it was a family
recipe and they don't need to know my
friends
green chef is a usda certified organic
company and includes recipes for
paleo keto and even plant power diets so
yes there's something
for everybody you will not be left out
green chef is actually owned
by hello fresh and you guys know i've
endorsed them before so you already know
how much i love them and how delicious
the food is and green chef is just as
good my genius brain listeners go to
greenchef.combrain80 to get eighty
dollars off including free shipping once
again
go to greenchef.com brain80 to get
80 off including free shipping
and get to grubbin my babies i dealt
with it before
but he started dealing with it later on
in his life but he actually had crazy
sleep apnea
yes and it was because of how overweight
he was yeah
there are things for us when we lost
this weight
it was beyond way beyond the surface
level of just wanting to
look good and feel good in terms of a
mentality thing yeah
i physically wasn't paid yeah literally
physical like okay so
um sleep apnea you if you're obese you
understand it like
you wake up groggy all the [ __ ] time
and that was my [ __ ] since high school
i never woken up like yeah like i had a
great day
that i didn't realize that until i
actually lost the weight because i've
been overweight my whole life
and did you ever take this that the
passing a test i had to do a sleep study
i just stay over at night yeah
how much did you like stop breathing a
night i can't remember now but it was a
[ __ ] ton
yeah it was like yeah
like [ __ ] like that i i
in a seven hour period apparently i
stopped breathing
like 500 times in the night
i only got 30 of the oxygen my brain was
supposed to get damn i can't remember my
numbers but it was
i don't think it was a bad issue it was
[ __ ] bad bro and it was like
so in that time i'm like okay looking
for antidepressants
we were talked about it back uh before
in the last podcast uh
by advance um and um anti-anxiety all
these things
until i was like i need a cpap machine
i remember that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
bane oxygen masking that you had
yeah and guess what i had to get it took
two weeks to get used to breathing with
a [ __ ] tight mask on my face but god
damn it i woke up
although i was obese my brain was so
clear
and i was making the right decisions i
was i was getting my [ __ ] together and i
was starting to lose weight
cpap machine literally lost 20 pounds
from there
yeah you know and that's where we can
start with like obesity and [ __ ] like
man if you're out there and you're like
morbidly obese
talk to your doctor about a cpap machine
just go out there and do it it's
important
you know the the like for me when i was
doing the whole weight loss thing
like i never took a second to realize
how fat i was right because i was just
living life it just is what it is
my weight was never got in the way of me
getting the things that i wanted in life
yeah whether it was me being a stand-up
comic
career choices be talking to women or
whatever your your subscriber count was
going
every year anyway there was there was
nothing that it was i guess in terms
career-wise or even
my personal life social life-wise it
wasn't getting in the way right
and i i think that because of this this
rhetoric of
you know you should be able to love
yourself at all times 100 agree
i was there but it didn't change the
fact that i wasn't healthy
yes and i think that was the the thing
that i was kind of convoluting these two
things together
well i love myself i don't have to lose
weight but it's like if you do love
yourself
in my mind i never thought about
shouldn't you take care of your body too
you know these these knee pains that you
have you know when you play basketball
your knees hurt because you think you're
[ __ ] jordan over here
you know yeah um you're not really
thinking about these things and it was
waking up feeling exhausted all the time
never getting good sleep
going on a run full sprint when you just
need to walk
exactly there's these small things that
i never really considered
and i gotta say too after i lost the
weight i
i was a lot happier i was less angry
less anxious it helped me a lot with my
anxiety to be honest with you
and it just it felt really good and now
i'm at the point now
where if i don't exercise i or i don't
move around a little bit
i get really sad i get really just out
of whack
so let's ask all the david soul fans out
there you upset that this guy lost
weight
you upset about that you want him to be
unhappy
and overweight and dying like come on
guys like
i mean for the lizzo fans come on guys
she's
getting it that's what i'm saying they
they are not fans of
her they are fans of the identity of the
identity
and so i can only imagine what it's like
for lizzo
you know as somebody who was
it's like i can't win like whether i'm
fat
you [ __ ] hate me if i'm losing weight
and i'm doing things for myself
you [ __ ] hate me so why the [ __ ]
should i care at this point so i feel
terrible for her
it's like she can't just live you have
to now like shut off your fans
who are against you for being healthy
like um i okay it's weird i relate
i never would say i relate to liz
in that way where man i had some [ __ ]
haters when i was losing weight yeah
i couldn't believe it yeah i couldn't
believe
people who were like would be like
yo you're taking a lot of selfies these
days give me a break man
look at my face man i'm a different
person yeah you know like
oh why are you taking shirtless pictures
oh you're taking a lot of selfies
and i'm like i i thought about it
outside of my relationship with this
person like
why is this guy putting me down why is
this person doing that
you know and then i had to actually
think about this [ __ ] about okay then
i like stepped off social media for a
while
even though i lost weight um until i was
like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this person and [ __ ]
whoever whatever yes i lost my [ __ ]
weight from my
[ __ ] goddamn self and i've got
this
new [ __ ] going on so i started like
[ __ ] [ __ ] him
i'm doing my [ __ ] and if lizzle's out
there doing a [ __ ] like that's where i'm
a fan
who now like do your [ __ ] thing it
just sucks for somebody why does she
have to always
explain herself why do you yeah why why
does she have to explain
yo if the [ __ ] woman wants to lose
weight she wants to lose weight
what's that got to do with you you want
to be fat be fat
you [ __ ] yeah go do whatever the hell
you're doing
support her music and her artistry you
have something that you have to deal
on a mental scale that you have to deal
with that is not
her responsibility that is not the
responsibility of celebrities
entertainers or anything else
you keep deflecting your personal issues
onto other people expecting them to fix
your [ __ ] problems
and that is not their job it is her job
to do her job which is be a musician
live her life and be the happiest that
she can be if her being fat made you
happy
not her [ __ ] problem yeah i'm sorry
the core of like the problem of who
i think you did too i think you had
explained this earlier is that you
identified as being the fat guy
yeah you identified that i'm the fat
funny guy and
being funny is correlated with being fat
same with
like a little bit of me was just like i
am the fat guy kind of thing i've
accepted that yeah my whole life until
it was just like do i really
[ __ ] have to be yeah you don't
and it's almost like you're doing it to
make other people feel comfortable yeah
what kind of [ __ ] is that
why do i have to make you feel
comfortable you know what about me
you know and it gets and i think like
people were really upset too with like
that whole situation because they were
like was adele getting the same type of
thing it's like you were our big girl
were you in our big girl moment
you know like why is lizzo getting this
type of [ __ ] she's like was she aware
that she was in your big girl movement
yeah or did you know that maybe
like all of you as well wish that you
were half the size you were
yeah where it would benefit you on
on so many scales like in health as well
and like
look the honest truth is like when i
lost the weight holy [ __ ] society teach
like treats me so much better bro when i
lost the weight
from when i was before uh yeah you could
see
people really do treat you better and
from the way i looked and felt before to
the way i do
now um it's unfair
it's just not fair and yeah but it's
just the way it is
and like welcome to our reality you know
but you can't [ __ ]
bend reality to be like
almost dying is beautiful yeah
stop making loopholes for god [ __ ]
sake
if you are having like to this day i
have um i have scar tissue on my back i
had these bumps on my lower back because
of what how
[ __ ] fat i was yeah and i had back
problems
when i was fat as [ __ ] i couldn't tie my
goddamn shoes bro
damn it was sad i was like
yeah i'm holding my breath yeah and i'm
tying my shoes
yeah yeah yeah cause my gut was so big
yeah you know
all right and then i had to figure out
ways to do it it's just like
stop pretending like that's okay yeah
i'm telling you guys i was there with
you i was
[ __ ] there it was hard i'm [ __ ]
sweating my ass off in a movie theater
a lot of the things that happened to
what i figured out for myself was that
i started normalizing discomfort in
paris yes
you know like yeah my knee should hurt
my back when i go down these stairs my
titty should jiggle a little yeah oh
yeah this
yeah that's normal there's this ankle
bone this extra fat
extra thing you have going on yeah you
know you start to normalize
pain every day but then when you start
to make healthier choices right
and you and these pain this pain goes
away
it's like oh this is how life should be
you know this is great you know it's
like when i figured out i had anxiety
and i learned to just
yeah hey oh you're freaking out over
stupid [ __ ] and i started gaining
control of it and i'm like oh i don't
like the way that feels
yeah it it sucks that on a public scale
like i said you have to
nobody should sit there and come up to
you and be like hey you're a fat [ __ ]
like you're an [ __ ] if you do that
stuff i know yeah
but but i know i'm fat but i'm not a
[ __ ]
i don't need you to tell me you know
like i'm not talking about that because
i i know what it's like for somebody to
go ahead and try to poke at you
poke fun at you at your weight right
which is why i had to develop a sharp
tongue yeah and start going back at
people all the time
um but if we're talking about this in
terms of like health
you're not gonna and i read these
articles all the time where they kind of
they want to be a contrarian and they're
trying to find the one
the the one exception to the rule and
they use that as the basis of their
argument for help yeah right they go
well there's this one person who runs
marathons that i know that they're
technically obese but they run marathons
like cool
do you yeah like you know
that's them proud of them do you
see we're trying to rationalize these
things because you
in reality don't like the way you look
and feel
and i know because i was there too yeah
right so
if that's if you are going to have it's
hard enough that you have to [ __ ]
argue with these
judging annoying ass people on the
outside but then you have to deal with
yourself
doing that to you all the time too so
which is the one that you can address
can you address somebody else's behavior
first or can you address your behavior
first
you can address yours it's a lot easier
that way for you to say oh [ __ ]
damn david why is it that when you can't
eat your hot dog you get mad
you might have a [ __ ] food addiction
yeah you might be addicted
to processed foods and a lot of carbs
and fat
why is it that you get mad when somebody
says you can't have your taco
are you a [ __ ] what's wrong with you
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in essence that critical thinking that
you're doing where you're asking
yourself the right questions
lizzo fans ask yourself if lizzo is
doing something good
so that she can live a long life and
continue making great music
why are you upset who are you upset
about
yeah i heard you said it yourself yeah
you know yeah that's it's something that
i've always
you know i want to be very careful in
terms of i don't ever want people
to feel bad about how they look and feel
right
and you know we're doing that we have
this movement of trying to normalize
things like i'll normalize being fat
i think being fat is normalized yeah i
think there's more fat people
in the society it's just part of our
culture it's okay
we accept it there's always going to be
fat people no matter what right yeah but
the one thing that i can't agree with
and this is somebody who was 280 pounds
is to say that being fat i was healthier
[Laughter]
oh no you know
no people are trying to convince other
people right now it's like you know
technically
you know these skinny people doesn't
mean that they're healthier a hundred
percent yeah
but but when people are
a certain weight it's been proven
multiple times you could find the
statistical data in the studies that
that most likely that they are
healthier than you that they will live a
little longer than you right
yeah there are a lot of exceptions to
those rules we're not talking about
skinny crackheads
we're not talking about that we're
talking about just normal people who
have a normal diet
i i think what we have to be honest
about as fat people
like i know i'm not physically fat now
but i'm just gonna speak
it as a fat boy because i was there we
have excuses
is our specialty yeah you know we are
the king of
such excuses and making loopholes around
it to convince ourselves that we're
otherwise healthy
it's only because you're just used to
being fat
and not realizing that you know you
could actually run for 10 miles
and not get too tired if you weren't 100
pounds overweight
yeah you know and i was shocked at how
[ __ ] far i could run
after i lost all this weight once yeah
you know because i had never
like cause you know like i just had the
thought of what obesity was
all wrong because you know you
you think that being obese is normal and
whatever it's just
not carrying a backpack full of 100
pounds
and thinking you can go play basketball
is the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever
yeah so i [ __ ] up my knees yeah you
know and
it yeah like i said there was there was
a mental journey that happened
uh before i lost this weight and a lot
of the times too
i think a lot of people fail at getting
healthier
is because the my state isn't right
before they approach this stuff right
they're not really addressing the real
issues that they have with their
unhealthy habits
so when i every time i try to lose
weight it was like okay i'm going to
smash these [ __ ] weights
i'm going to try to run these extra
miles and then really
i didn't address number one was what
food does to my body
how my body works when i eat certain
foods and why i'm fat in the first place
your addiction
you know it probably would have helped
if i just went to a [ __ ] therapist
but i had to figure it out myself you
know
so it took a lot longer but i gotta be
honest i'm talking here like i [ __ ]
got all the answers and [ __ ] but like
i had a very different experience yeah
um
no i'll tone it down because i'm being
very self-aware about my
[ __ ] cockiness right now but um
yeah i uh i took some steps beforehand
because i did take therapy
yeah you know um and
the the therapy with the cpap machine
did help me realize the what i was
saying is
the fat logic the loopholes we create
and excuses we create to allow us to be
fat
it's because though around the world
around us is generally accepting
obesity look it's okay we should
intrinsically love each other
right at the same time like we got to be
aware that
like that morbid obesity is just not
okay like to that level where you're
like anywhere near 300 pounds as a human
being no matter how tall you are
is pushing it sometimes you know and i
feel like some people have to
like obviously i was talking like i knew
all that [ __ ] but like
um every other person really has to get
into their place where they like see
like now's the time
now's the time right yeah there's gonna
be a moment and
and i'm pretty sure there's somebody
who's gonna be listening to this right
now
and first when you hear this you might
be a little upset yeah
because sorry guys i'm so sorry you know
you might you might be a little upset
because
when you hear these words like fat it
becomes a trigger word for you right
so even but let me just switch that word
around and i said unhealthy right
and sometimes when people some people
even say
when it comes to being obese there is uh
it's it's uh it's like mentally
unhealthy
yeah right and for me it was i can only
speak about this for uh from personal
experience right
is because i made these personal excuses
right like i remember i even told my dad
my dad was like
hey why don't you just get down to like
230 pounds it's like dude i was like
dude that's impossible for me
i literally told him it's impossible i
was like dude look at this [ __ ] frame
bro
you know you start doing something i was
like just like dude this frame yeah
if i don't know 2 30 like i'll be dead
you know i'm 211 right now
yeah i'm still chubby so what the [ __ ]
was i thinking
and so when my dad said that to me he
was saying it out of
a concern for my health and i took his
words and i took it as an attack
yeah you know and this is stuff that i
had to deal with consistently
but at the end of the day when you make
these choices for yourself you have to
realize that
if there's no nobody else in the room
it's just you and your life choices
if you're okay with being making these
unhealthy life choices right
that's fine that's on you i think you
should be very careful about telling
people that you being unhealthy is
healthy yeah
because there is an adverse effect about
that i'm not talking about
the societal issue of people going out
of their way to make people feel bad
about their life choices
i don't think that's if it doesn't
really affect you on a personal scale
then shut the [ __ ] up and leave them
alone you should be going out telling
people that they're fat you terrible
[ __ ]
but at the same time i'm not to be a
part of the side to say that being obese
is
uh healthy i i personally don't think
that's the case
and i think it's not from the case it's
also from from a mental point too
the fact that you're addicted to food
you can't
you're not using food for what it's used
for yeah it can be pleasurable but at
the same time
you don't get your twinkie you start
throwing a fit you might have an
addiction
yeah i think that's uh one of the things
that you know if you go
through um like aaa
like uh this the 12-step program or
whatever
like it applies to you know these people
too
and like um where you really have to
face
like your denial you know um
considering your height and your weight
you really have to face
like what you're like a healthy weight
actually is
and then you were saying too like a lot
of us when we're obese
we like how was that healthy the how was
165 the healthy weight from my height or
whatever i'm like that's impossible
yeah that's [ __ ] 90 pounds dude
i mean yo it's because i'm so
morbidly obese yeah it's it's hard to
kind of picture yourself in that
situation right or in that weight
and you know there's people that i know
now they still ask me for the same
[ __ ] advice they go
how did you lose weight how did you lose
weight and i give them the same thing
and they don't want to distance and they
don't listen they don't do it it's like
why are you asked then right you know my
god
it's like i i you want to do it your way
right i'm going to tell you i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be the contrarian in your life
and i'm gonna tell you that's not the
way to do it
not just because of the way that i
personally feel that it worked for me
which is basically where it's coming
from right but at the same time if
you're gonna ask me and i give you this
advice and you think it's [ __ ] why
do you keep coming to me
obviously you haven't figured it out
you've you've hated the way that you
felt for the past whatever 30 odd years
20 some odd years now
and you want to change it but you still
don't want to do it in the way that
other people
can advise you who have been in your
situation
what's what do you think is going to
happen you're going to fail again and
then you're going to go into this spiral
depression
you're going to eat more because it
comforts you then you're going to come
back and say
ah i did it again how do i do it again
you're not addressing the right issues
you have to you have to figure out your
why first
why am i like this why am i addicted to
food why do i enjoy this
yeah well for me it was
when i turned 30 not fat as [ __ ]
and i'm like you know i'm 30 now and i'm
like
not doing well and whatever and then
there was a whole lot of steps you were
saying like the why
why why kind of thing that you have to
face
and really take up on your own and
for all the [ __ ] that you did say
about fat shaming or skinny shame or
skinny people or fat
whatever right it's okay to reassess
what you used to think you know and your
judgments
and whatever and like uh take it back to
zero
you know like where you are and how you
feel and what must be done
you know and like it's okay to want to
lose weight it is not a sin
you know like in it and it really
wouldn't be like
like yeah attack on your identity like
that's what i was trying to
i think bring up earlier like being fat
is not your identity the way you
speak and laugh and tell your stories
and relate to your friends has
nothing to do with the fact that you're
fat yeah
it's because there's so much more to you
beyond being fat while your friends love
you
yeah and and to to wrap it back to you
know the lizzo situation
i think that's really what she's
fighting for right now like let me live
yeah like let me be me yeah let me be
this
artist why is it that anytime i i have
some type of
accolade or i reach a certain level of
success
it's always in the back burner of me
being a fat person or being in the front
of this fat movement
like could you imagine how terrible that
could make that would make me feel
terrible right
imagine if all your friends and all your
fans actually i mean your fans
you look through their pictures and they
all look like you might be hilarious
you know a bunch of davidson looking
like they're all three there's a kid
that i met
there's a kid that i met uh he's like a
box he's like a kickboxer too right and
he's
this full he goes hey man can i tell you
something dude like
i was like really skinny and i i looked
up to you so much about the kid i got
fat
this kid [ __ ] got fat
because he loved me so much and then he
goes like yeah then
you know like i still watch your [ __ ]
and then i saw you losing weight and i'm
like
[ __ ] i'm fat and i started losing weight
so there's a lot of weight again
[ __ ] come on follow
it's like i'm also making people feel
okay about certain things
that even i'm not okay feeling yeah like
because i'm lying to myself yeah like
how terrible
how terrible is that so now i have to
undo the bad things that i did
because i didn't take the time to really
think about my mental health and how i
felt about my weight
and i put on my insecurities onto other
people and then they followed suit
so now i have to fix that [ __ ] because i
had to take that responsibility
so i was like [ __ ] man like all these
little kids that got fat because of me
i'm like oh
[ __ ] like i have to like uh
okay so like i started a
kido group chat with people at my church
because they saw me losing weight and
they wanted to join in and learn how to
all pastors should try it out pastors
are [ __ ] fatty
yup get on that but um
i think i realized that um
you might feel this way too that even
your method was specifically tailored to
you and your body and when people ask
you how to do it they're like
what the [ __ ] is this right like how did
you do this how could you do this or
whatever
and as much as people ask me how i lost
a hundred pounds i'm just
like at this point i'm almost like if i
told you you're not gonna do it so
just like you it's tailored to you and
what you're comfortable with you can do
any diet usually i just say just stop
eating sugar
and you can do any diet you want fast 16
hours and stop eating sugar and you'll
lose weight that's it and you'll do any
diet you want well like the
that's what i'm saying it's the
the reason why people fail at having a
healthier lifestyle in terms of weight
is because they're never addressing the
real issues right
so the methodology is different
everybody has different methods
some people lose weight because they uh
they worked out
a ridiculous amount they run 10 miles a
day
they weight train but they still eat and
they eat a little healthier and they
lose a [ __ ] ton
of weight yeah because they cause they
burn the calories that they bring in
calorie and calorie out
is actually really that simple right
some people do uh
ketosis right which is which i always
found hilarious
because because everybody's like just do
keto i'm like but you're still fat
so why would i do keto you know i'm like
you know keto is hard
but it works for certain people i have i
have to remind myself the way i
talk sometimes like it's a [ __ ]
matter of fact like i just did earlier
like
you know what i i do crazy things
i go to iraq to make sure that's real
yeah so
the way i did keto just just there's
only two people i know that did keto
that did well it's you and my friend
john
yeah and that's that's two out of like
80 people
you know yeah and what i found out is
for it works with specific people yeah
so you just got to figure out what works
well for you
i don't know the science behind it per
se whether it's healthier or healthier
or not i know it's worked for certain
people and they kept it off
and their blood works fine so i who am i
to say anything else right so what i
mean by when i say address the reasons
why you're fat
i'm not talking about just what you're
eating it's a mental thing
why are you okay with being this way do
you know what food does to your body and
do you know that you have a food
addiction yeah if you can address
that then you could address the other
problems because the foundation is now a
lot stronger
what you eat every day every day
what did i eat every day what was your
addiction every day
[Laughter]
probably four or five times a week whoa
you drove from like
stop pass all the way over there all the
time damn bro it's a dollar tacos it's
literally
literally that's behind
there so it's like i ate there all the
time and i ate laminate all the time
which you know this is these are this is
just science facts by the way and this
is what i found out through reading a
lot
i mean your body is you have two sources
of energy right you're
it's either carbohydrates like sugars or
you're gonna be is fats
so when you go into ketosis you use fat
right and then
typically what everybody else runs on is
carbs and sugars right carbohydrates
that's as simple as it gets
problem so when you eat stuff like high
carb high fat you have two energy
sources which is why a lot of us are fat
yeah you will gain weight
and so that's as simple as it gets yeah
you know so if you kind of know that and
when you look at your plate you go hold
hold on a second
butter rice probably one
sugar yeah i have too many energy
sources here and what am i going to do
today
lay down and watch a movie yeah do i do
i need this
do i need all this energy yes excess so
that
it it allowed me to kind of flip my
plate up
one of the things you told me that
changed my whole outlook and
really changed the game for me with keto
was when you said
cooking is alchemy you said cooking is
chemistry it's science bro
and i was like oh [ __ ] that's when i
started sous-viding all my food
and i started [ __ ] shedding i just
want to tell you that you take something
and you're turning into something else
that it isn't it's [ __ ] alchemy trust
the science guys
trust the science count your macros
calories in calories out
yeah you know know your balance between
whether you're going into ketosis or
you're running on carbs
that's why when people are like calorie
counting is evil
listen i understand what you mean but
the reason why i believe in calorie
counting i don't calorie count now
because i don't need to yeah because but
what it did it gave me a basis to
understand the foods that i'm eating
it's mathematics it's mathematics so
it's like oh
i thought i wasn't eating much but then
when i calori when i counted all the
calories like oh i ate 4 200 calories a
day
yeah but [ __ ] i wouldn't have realized
that unless i
and then i'm like ah this is a little
excessive yeah you know maybe i should
bring it down
300 calories next week so instead of 4
200 it's gonna be 3 800 and i'm like oh
i'm not that hungry
and then you start bringing it down a
little more after a while when you start
to once again do the research and you
understand what food does to you
then the calorie counting kind of goes
away yeah it's like oh because i could
look at a plate and be like
i know this is going to make me fool i'm
good right but it gives you a good
foundation
a tool is is only what the what the what
the person who use it makes it
right if you want to use it in detriment
to yourself that's not the tools problem
that's the individual's issue
calorie counting and macro counting
works like somebody was like i don't
believe in that stuff like
i was like as a nutritionist i was like
if you're a nutritionist
and you do people's diets you calorie
count for them yeah
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what's that mean and he was like well
that's different cause i do it for so
you do believe me shut the [ __ ] up
what are you talking about i think he's
probably talking about changing people's
mindset
about exactly it's like yeah i i did
count
all my calories in the beginning and it
i did it for about a month only
and then after that i was like i kind of
can see it now yeah
you know you just read the macros of
like okay
so uh case in point i'm doing keto so
i'm making sure i'm having 70 of my diet
is fat
you know and 20 is um
proteins and then 10 of it is
that's why everybody [ __ ] about keto
yeah they don't realize how much fat
that they have to have
and so they overload on proteins yeah
they're still fat
because those proteins turn to carbs
thank god for khalif khalif thank you so
much you told me that
he's like stop drinking so many protein
shakes man like yeah you're not even
working out
but um yeah i mean like you look connect
to the good friends who do care like if
you ever if you're a fat guy and you get
a
a healthy guy trying to give you
unsolicited advice
just i know it's like salty and [ __ ]
just take the time to process what
they're trying to tell you bro yeah
like like it they're telling you some
good information
you know that's that's the that's one
when i always tell people who
they they ask me to i want to try keto
and i'm like you could but i suggest you
do other things first because keto is
hard
and they're like what do you mean i was
like you know you still have to count
your calories and then on top of that
you have to count your carbs and your
fats
like to be crazy it's very particular
you have to get yourself into ketosis
yeah i was like
that if you can do that you can actually
do a regular healthy diet
yeah you know i think keto works for
people who
um number one enjoy that type of food
and people who have more simple palettes
when i found out
simple i'm such a simple [ __ ] man as
a fat guy
i love eating hawaiian barbecue you know
under the lamb
chinese food teriyaki yeah
and danny's spaghetti is that simple
that's all i wanted every [ __ ] day
and that's what i had
right but then yeah it's it's to reverse
all that [ __ ] was to just like count out
the carbs and sugars
you know and hack my body into ketosis
learn the science of that whatever like
to each his own i'm not gonna have to
explain it here but the mindset to have
to get in there is really to have to ask
yourself how long do you want to live
yeah right that's it's really true
though
literally when i hear people saying fat
acceptance is like you're okay with
dying at 40.
not even that the quality of life
because you might be able to live longer
but i want to live a quality life to
when i till i die yeah and there has
never been a person around me
that was morbidly obese that lived into
a later age
that didn't have the worst time ever
bro yo to my obese brothers and sisters
do you know what it's like to wipe your
own ass
you want to be able to wipe your own ass
you want to hear something [ __ ] funny
dude
like i remember when i just started
eating healthier and you know my
shits were going a little crazy in the
water but i remember at a certain point
it just i just had
clean shits all the time and i'm like so
you're not supposed to have diarrhea
[Laughter]
that's what i'm saying look look yeah as
obese people were used to
being unhealthy i'm like so dire it's
not supposed to happen
every day yeah you know [ __ ] yeah i'm
not supposed to
not be able to breathe when i time my
shoes yeah
like all these things that i thought
were normal for being unhealthy come
into check i'm like man dude my poops
are solid
all the time i'm like is this normal
life
you know i sleep every night very well i
can time my shoes
i can you know do so many do you have to
take a lot of supplements when you do
keto or no
i do i do like um the
i don't know what you want to call uh
disclaimer i take one of these men
because i eat tom yoser and kimchi every
day yeah i do the korean barbecue diet
that's pretty new for me yeah meat
without marinade
uh dark leafy greens um
no sugary panchons no sugary drinks no
diet coke
no shout out to dan you [ __ ]
got us he addicted to diet coke you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this i hated diet coke but he would
drink diet coke like it was the most
delicious thing he's ever seen
just for the taste of it diet coke
and then i started liking diet coke he's
like dude he doesn't have calories and
i'm like damn dude you're a genius
yeah no little didn't mean no
aspartame is the pepper yeah and so you
know that's why i don't drink diet coke
anymore
yeah i had to learn how to you know say
goodbye to that [ __ ] and all that
whatever
but yeah what was the issues with with
keto
i don't know i haven't read too much
about i didn't have issues with keto
yeah i know there was like something
about some supplements that you should
take or some [ __ ] like that i don't know
what it is but
i mean it's just like make sure your b12
count is up so you have energy when
you're like
uh having sugar withdrawals um make i'm
drinking smart water all the [ __ ]
time
you know i make sure i sometimes i take
hydration tablets
to make sure i'm staying hydrated
because of the i fasted a lot too
uh keto makes your poop like [ __ ]
rabbit pellets
so you want to get your fiber somehow
but you can't take metamucil
you know because they actually have has
sugary carbs in it
oh really yeah like i i tried [ __ ]
every i really
did everything that counted but you had
a headache but the kimchi helps though
right the kimchi
kim seaweed i did the korean barbecue
diet just
no sauce no rice no soju and
that'd be so hard for me to have kim kim
cheese upside and not a piece of rice
nope no rice that's just so hard for me
because like it's like that's the
missing piece
yeah oh look at me look at me right now
surprise damn a piece of rice inside
this kim right now would kill
you know yeah it's the i'm gonna say the
discipline i guess
is the only thing i can chalk it up to
for you it helped you out mentally
though a lot mentally
like the mental clarity that you gained
from it was like the biggest thing the
adhd
uh i told i said earlier um bivance
adderall
methamphetamines don't actually help my
adhd
my dyslexia and just a whole lot of
cognitive functions
that i lost a hundred pounds kind of
thing and i was
trying to figure out what was wrong with
me but like what i learned with
uh let's say fasting in ketosis they
work hand in hand very well
you guys can google that [ __ ] and figure
out why but like
man i can tell my lefts and rights yeah
i don't were you ever in a car with me
when you like turn right and i just
turned [ __ ] left so did it last time
we're in the car
he was like hey turn right here and it
was and he put his left
[ __ ] sheepsec my dyslexia bro
yo on ketosis my dyslexia is gone
i'm not even kidding like in ketosis i
don't have to read
a sentence three times to comprehend it
in ketosis i don't need
i don't like my cognitive function and
focus is all there
yeah when i want to talk about the [ __ ]
i want to talk about kind of thing
and it's really put myself into motion
now in my 30s it's one of those things
like yeah i wish i had in high school
maybe i would have done better my
functions
and [ __ ] but like uh you know
at least i'm just here and now in the
moment like where i am ketosis works for
me
i could have quit it two years ago after
i already hit my goal
but the way i actually got off it for
about a few
months and i went back to eating [ __ ]
gained 20 pounds and i was like i need
but you didn't feel good i didn't feel
good at all this is what we were just
talking about like you don't know
what you're missing because you've never
had it yeah so when you start feeling
really good and you start introducing
these stuff back into your life
it's it feels terrible yeah like i was
you know the best thing that happened
with corona was the fact that i had to
go back to eating healthier foods
and i started feeling better like all my
gut problems went away all that other
stuff and then
i'm like i d bloated and i felt better
you know every time i shoot a cent foods
guys it's uh
pretty terrible in the bathroom for me
it's pretty bad
so the aftermath of it just the diarrhea
the diarrhea i get like
sleep apnea dude the lethargy that i get
super sluggish my brain's in the fog
the acne that i get from it it's not
it's fun it's dope eating all that food
but to eat six restaurants yeah in a
matter of two hours it's kind of rough
and i usually don't eat like that
normally so when that happens i get
[ __ ] up really bad
so [ __ ] thrillers dude they're such a
funny company they hit they remember
we were going through email they're like
yeah we're gonna do a new season i'm
like dope
okay so we're going to shoot uh six days
back to back i'm like
[ __ ] you you nuts
you [ __ ] nuts guys like you do you
want to kill me
are you insane i'm like oh that's right
i'm like yeah nobody wants it
yeah i physically die every time i shoot
man versus food dude
oh he came out with that right like how
terrible it made him feel yes it was
killing him on the inside yeah
yeah man i mean yeah i mean just to go
back to what we're talking about like
you know health and body positivity
i feel like those are two just separate
things you know i
i realize that i cannot be the
influencer to teach you how to do these
things because
sorry uh ketosis is for specific people
to be honest
yeah yeah yeah that's what i realized i
i thought i was gonna do the david
goggins train and be like i'm just like
you guys
i used to be fat as [ __ ] and anybody can
do keto you know what
not everybody can do it i realize that
now they [ __ ] suffer under keto
i get keto rash on my chest it doesn't
itch or whatever
it it's my natural keto like detector i
don't have to do a blood thing or pee
thing i see it when i get the rash
and then somebody else i knew like was
doing the keto thing
it [ __ ] bothered the [ __ ] out of her
she couldn't stand it and i didn't
understand and i was like what the [ __ ]
yeah and i saw where i did wrong where i
wasn't like
weakling you can't [ __ ] do kiddo yeah
i was wrong
i was wrong yeah you guys have to go out
there and like dude there's some there's
dozens of diets
just the the thing i learned about
what worked for me even though
genetically maybe keto works best
it's the effort i put in 100
to make sure like i'm doing this right i
didn't cheat a little bit here that'd be
like
yeah you know maybe if i had a little
bit of this maybe a little bit no not
even one grape i didn't
eat fruit i don't eat potatoes i don't
eat onions i don't eat garlic i don't
eat like i went
[ __ ] straight and then i had to
realize
look i'm extreme i take extreme measures
it has to be possibility that not
everyone does it like i do
and to do keto you have to do it 100
every person that i know that failed
they would come back and they would say
that's some of the funniest [ __ ] to me
because they
they would do it right and they're like
i'm not losing weight because i know
more about keto and they're doing it
yeah you know because it was one of the
options that i wanted to try
and i just couldn't do it like it was
hard it was so [ __ ] hard
you know like i wanted fruits you know
that's the sugar addiction
yeah it's the sugar and then they're
like yeah man like i'm eating like
all these meats and stuff like that i'm
like meats what do you mean meats
and he was like yeah like steaks and
eggs and something
i was like bro what's your protein
intake he goes what do you mean i'm like
you're not counting your pro your
protein in your fat intake it has to be
like 70 percent
yeah and he goes no i'm eating a lot of
fatty food what's your protein intake
and so and i was like you know you also
have to be in a calorie deficit
he goes wait he goes i can't just eat
whatever i'm like no he said well why do
people do this i was like
you do you tell me you know
it's gotta work out for you like like
okay
cause you're still calorie in calories
you still have to be in a calorie
deficit you [ __ ]
i had to really really like take my ocd
to a point where
i had to pretend i was 200 000 years ago
caveman
yeah and be like i'm not gonna eat for
three days
just like my ancestors who are out on
the hunt until they find some teji in
mongolia
yeah you know and then then i'll i'll
i'm simulating
the fast i'm simulating ketosis i'm
simulating the hunt
i'm simulating the feeding period it's
so funny too you know you say that
because i
during this time when i was losing
weight you know what my favorite show
was naked and afraid
yeah and i'm like these people aren't
dying
yeah you know but it's true though like
during
it it's this idea of i'm starving yeah i
was like are you
it's like david you just ate 2 800
calories now you're starving
how are you starving instead i'm
starving i want food you want
food and what i had to attribute to
myself
too i'm not going to say it for everyone
like when i felt the hunger pains i
realized it was more or less my sugar
withdrawals yeah i was finding
for sugar and um that's what those
hunger pains and those headaches and
then like shakes and whatever
and where when you're talking about
those supplements that i need
you know the one a day's men the b12
vitamins
the manganese magnesium the potassium
and because you can't eat
bananas oh that's right right so find
potassium without bananas
you know like that kind of [ __ ] like um
yeah i i just played it straight and
when i laid would lay it out to everyone
and just write this
outline [ __ ] this they go [ __ ] it
so i'm like you just wasted my time for
having to explain all this [ __ ] to you
bro
then don't [ __ ] do it or don't ask me
yeah and i got salty like that
honestly but then i am now learning
especially just literally right now
because i was being an [ __ ] over here
that not everyone's me yeah and everyone
has their own journey that's why i
always tell people that's just
when people always approach me with the
keto stuff i'm like damn that's like
saying like
like i'm gonna drive to san francisco
but i'm gonna drive through a mountain
first time
you know it's like why don't you just uh
go to the to the road that's already
paved
you know it's it might be a little
faster but it's a pretty treacherous
road yeah
you know and i like i said you're gonna
have to keep it up if it works for you
it works for you try it out
i mean like i said i don't i'm not a
doctor so i don't really [ __ ] know
and there might be somebody that will
actually keto is it i don't know
i haven't researched that part but i
know what food does for my body and i've
lost weight that way and i can do it
again and i know what food does for my
body and i can lose that
weight that way i but then like the
individual
really like oh man the personal journey
it starts there like because what we all
understand
is that food was our coping mechanism
yeah it was super that's all i did with
it
something else underlying beneath that
the reason why
you went to food yeah yeah you got to
find that you got to find that part and
that's
that's going to be the the hard part
actually happy journey guys
hey i was right there if you guys need
some help just dm me and i probably
won't respond
but hey guys that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast we
talked about some really random [ __ ] but
if you guys uh
disagree or agree write it in the
comments below you can find ed at ed
parkvp on instagram
and every thursdays and sundays is
another genius brain
episode baby love your love you very
much love yourself as much as i love you
you guys are
awesome stay safe guys peace peace